Thanks for that example Susan. Now it's explicit memory that really requires us
to have ability to retrieve information. For example, you're going to need to
retrieve what you've learned from this lesson to pass the problem set to the
exam. However, there's often times that we don't encode the information
properly. Or we don't store it properly so it can't be retrieved. And as we're
going to see, sometimes people will retrieve information that's incorrect. This
is termed False Memories. Now, false memories are memories of events that never
actually happened. Elizabeth Loftus is a pioneer in the research on false
memories. One study she did was had participants listen to a fictitious story
of being lost in a shopping mall. A family member of the participant would
describe this event to them, and 25% of the participants remembered being lost
in a shopping mall. Even though that never actually happened. So what does this
tell us about memory?